hi i'm eric voss and spider-man into the
spider-verse is a joy of a film
it's a true celebration of everything
spider-man start to finish including the
true finish of every superhero movie
these days the post-credits scene i'm
gonna break it down explain what it is
so
you don't have to fake those laughs when
your friends bring it up by the way
don't feel bad pretty much everyone's
faking these laughs there was like maybe
one guy in the theater you saw with who
actually got all of the references
probably looked like me before i begin
obviously spoiler warning i've really
just been installing these past couple
seconds to give you time to click away
in case you're one of those dummies who
clicks on an indian explanation video
for a movie you haven't seen yet
buzz off okay this movie is one actual
post-credits scene
but as the credits in we should point
out that the movie does take another
moment to honor stan lee
a card appears on the screen with the
image of stan lee's signature sunglasses
actually a similar image was tweeted by
producer chris miller not too long ago
and then one of stanley's more
well-known quotes a person who helps
others simply because
it should or must be done and because it
is the right thing to do
is indeed without a doubt a real
superhero and then it follows up with
thanks to stan lee and steve ditko for
showing us we're not the only ones
steve ditko is of course another
celebrated comic book artist who
co-created with stan lee spider-man
and other marvel characters like doctor
strange he also passed away this year
this past june
okay then we move on to the real in
credits scene a caption appears on
screen reading
meanwhile in nueva york a female
hologram blips in and out of a
futuristic looking setting
which we see from the point of view of
an unseen figure a person voiced by
oscar isaac
aka poe dameron from the star wars
movies you may have actually seen oscar
isaac's name roll by in the credits as
interesting person number one he asks
the hologram if she finished
assembling his goober remember that's
the name peter parker miles morales gave
the thumb drive device that they used to
destroy kingpin's collider but the
hologram corrects them and says that
it's a gizmo it's some kind of watch
device and hologram calls this unseen
figure miguel
so this spider-man is miguel o'hara aka
spider-man 2099 he is another alternate
universe spider-man
from the 90s relaunch of the character
that reimagined spider-man in a
futuristic new york miguel was really
the first
new and different spider-man to be
released in the comics miguel is a
rebellious but super smart prodigy who
ends up leading the genetics division of
the alchemix corporation his storyline
takes place over 100 years after what
was known as the heroic age of marvel
when the classic peter parker spider-man
stories took place miguel aims to
recreate the abilities of the original
spider-man which results in an accident
that alters 50
of his dna to become that of a spider
his costume is very cool
he actually made it for a day of the
dead celebration from material that he
called
unstable molecule fabric so that it
wouldn't rip this hologram that he's
talking to is an artificial intelligence
assistant named lila
it's really the only person miguel
trusts spider-man 29-9 story lines get
pretty wild they're a bit more violent
than a lot of the other spider-man
comics like it was early 90s comics were
weirdly lashing out a lot in those days
like miguel accidentally kills a guy
and he also fights vulture 2099 who's a
cannibal this 2099 run was pretty
popular but it was also kind of in its
own bubble since it's so futuristic
and nuts he does cross over with the
main spider-man from earth 616
swapping places with him so it makes
sense that the movie would feature him
in the post-credits scene but kept him
out of the main narrative now in this
scene lila gives him this special watch
that allows him to travel between
dimensions and miguel says that the
first place he wants to go
is the beginning one last time earth 67.
that's a reference to 1967 which is the
year that spider-man's retro 60s
animated show aired
it's a source of all those great 60
spider-man memes specifically the
spider-man pointing at spider-man meme
which is where miguel ends up
bickering with the 60 spider-man over
who's pointing at who who the heck
are you i just told you listen i'm from
the future how dare you point at me
you were pointing first it's rude to
point you're being very rude say jonah
jameson shows up telling a cop to
shoot spider-man obviously now this meme
is from an episode called
double identity it's where a villain
named charles cameo
dresses up as peter parker and
spider-man and steals a book
wow but you know how it goes this meme
has kind of taken on a life of its own
people use it for when two similar
people
need that you kind of ruin a meme by
trying to explain it it's really the
perfect reference point for a spider-man
movie which is filled with moments where
spider-man doppelgangers go what to each
other over and over again and because
they pick the best mix of spider people
it never gets old and i gotta say if end
of the spider-verse leads to a sequel
with miles morales joining spider-man
2099 with a team that also includes
retro 60s spider-man i am game like just
imagine getting the splashy living comic
book animation of miles and gwen stacy
plus the looney tune style movement of
spider-ham
plus the anime look of penny parker with
the occasional cutaway to a super
static letterbox spider-man who speaks
with big white letters so which
spider-man was your favorite and
spider-man into the spider-verse i
personally gotta go with peter porker
but i'm probably biased by seeing john
mulaney voicing that fight scene
ha
so great comment down below with your
favorite spider-man from the movie and
follow new rockstars on twitter and
instagram
new rockstars and follow me on twitter
and instagram eaboss
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns and explanations of all the
stuff you missed from stuff you love
yeah stuff
you